la salud de carlos menem había
desmejorado en los últimos años se había
empeorado especialmente en los últimos
meses tenía 90 años era senador de la
nación desde 2005 pero será
especialmente recordado por sus 10 años
de presidencia entre 1989 y 1999 sucedió
en el cargo a raúl alfonsín presidente
que había iniciado este ciclo
democrático que comenzó en 1983 alfonsín
terminó con serios problemas económicos
una hiperinflación y carlos saúl menem
llegó prometiendo un salariazo y una
revolución productiva pero terminó
implementando políticas de neto corte
neoliberal que incluyeron las grandes
privatizaciones de las principales
empresas del estado muchas personas
pasaron por momentos económicos muy
difíciles durante los gobiernos de
carlos saúl menem y su figura han sido
desde entonces muy polémica hay que ver
a partir de ahora cómo se empieza a
construir el recuerdo de este hombre que
también era muy peculiar gustaba de
juntarse con grandes estrellas del rock
de la música del mundo artístico se lo
recuerda manejando una
y jugando partidos de fútbol con sus
grandes patillas y pelo largo que
emulaban a la figura de los caudillos
históricos de la argentina de su natal
la rioja donde fue durante varios años
gobernador de la provincia el presidente
alberto fernández se expresó un profundo
pesar por su muerte y decretó tres días
de duelo nacional